cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north
devez pn écouter venom a eu la chance
d'accéder à de nouveaux programmes
télévisés comme notamment l'accusation
de spider man par le daily mail en
changeant de réalité et bien si je vous
disais que vous pouviez le faire vous
aussi dans une certaine mesure sans
avoir à bouger de chez vous eh bien oui
car grâce à north vpn et en un seul clic
vous pouvez changer votre localisation
depuis n'importe où pour accéder au
contenu de n'importe quel endroit par
exemple dans la réalité alternative que
vous connaissez sûrement sous le nom d'
états unis et bien si vous changez votre
localisation pour là bas vous pourrez
via disney plus voir chan chee ou encore
black widow qui sont sortis récemment et
ça c'est clairement un truc de fou ambre
est d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas que nord bp
n est accessible via six appareils
différents et surtout ses six appareils
seront sécurisés et protégés face aux
criminels et à la surveillance également
grâce à ses cinq mille 200 serveurs
répartis dans 60 pays norvez pn possède
une très bonne vitesse d'exécution donc
voilà mais ce n'est pas tout puisque
pour les fêtes de fin d'année vous
pouvez profiter d'une offre inédite de
deux ans avec 73 % de réduction et un
mois offerts satisfait ou remboursé sous
30 jours merci à north bay pn que la
vidéo commence
[Musique]
spider man way home sort dans moins de
deux semaines on va y arriver enfin ça
fait un peu bizarre je la boue comme je
vous avais dit dans la précédente vidéo
dédiée au trailer je souhaitais revenir
plus en détail sur certains éléments et
parler des grandes théories de noé home
avant sa sortie et c'est quelque chose
que l'on va faire aujourd'hui accompagné
en plus de mon variant rsf qui lui aussi
sort une vidéo et/ou j'apparaîtrai
dedans je vous conseille de vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait on va parler
pas mal de spider man après son film et
il ya d'autres thématiques intéressantes
et puis 2022 ça va être une année de fou
en vrai donc voilà je vous conseille de
le faire et puis bah écoute et on perd
pas de temps nous allons parler des
grands mystères de noé home allez c'est
parti
le premier grand point pour moi déjà à
élucider c'est le cas des sinister 6 de
ce que nous savons ces derniers vont
apparaître à cause du sort de strange
qui essayent de réécrire la réalité pour
faire oublier l'identité de spider man
dans la tête des gens de plus nous
savons qu'ils viennent des précédents
films de spider man avec tobey maguire
et andrew garfield et qu'ils vont mettre
un sacré bazar dans la réalité de
strange et le speedy de tom holland ce
qui va découler de ça c'est que peter va
avoir pour mission de les capturer et de
les enfermer dans le cul que strange va
lui donner sauf qu'une question morale
va ressurgir c'est que les sinister sont
destinés à mourir dans leur réalité face
à leurs spider man respectifs et c'est
quelque chose qui va confronter peter et
strange peter qui souhaite sauver le
monde tentera de voler le cube contenant
les sinister attrapés pour trouver une
solution tandis que strange va mettre en
cause la question du destin et que
changer leur destinée risque d'avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur l'univers donc
pour lui il faut les renvoyer dans leur
réalité même s'ils doivent mourir déjà
tout ça cela semble résonner comme la
première partie du film suit à far from
home peter va commencer à avoir de gros
soucis quant à la mort de mystérieux il
va voir strange le sort est lancée et
rate les réalité s'entremêlent avec
l'apparition des sinister il faut les
capturer et les renvoyer dans leur monde
au final un doute va se créer car peter
va apprendre qu'ils vont mourir et ne va
pas être d'accord donc il va y avoir une
confrontation avec strange et des
explications puis la logique voudrait
que les sinister apprennent à se
connaître dans la prison se libère et
s'allient pour justement créé le groupe
d sinister 6 néanmoins il ya tout de
même des choses intrigante dans la vidéo
précédente nous parlions de
l'incohérence de la survie du lézard et
l'homme sable dans leurs univers
respectifs du coupage émettait l'idée
potentiel que ce soit des variants du
coup s'il mourait mais cette idée ne
marche pas du tout car ils viennent bel
et bien des univers de sam raimi et demi
effectivement on ne sait pas ce qu'il
est advenu de ces derniers après
l'histoire des films ce qui veut dire du
coup que ceux ci sont morts plus tard et
new wave on va potentiellement nous
révéler ce qui leur est arrivé mais
également il faut que nous parlions des
changement de visuel apportées à
certains méchants de noé home comme par
exemple électro qui est à l'origine
bleus et qui fait cette fois ci des
éclairs jaune avec en plus un réacteur
arc de toni ou encore octopus avec la
nanotechnologie bref il faut une
explication cohérente par rapport à tout
ça par rapport à ces changements et j'en
ai peut-être une à vous proposer que
j'ai imaginé
la nature du sort de doctor strange est
plutôt ambigu et aucune indication ne
nous a été donnée par rapport à ça nous
en avons déjà beaucoup parler dans les
précédentes vidéos mais pour moi il est
clair que doctor strange tentent de
réécrire la réalité en se basant sur
d'autres univers pour effectuer son sort
ce qui me fait aller dans cette
direction c'est que déjà les arts
mystiques ont pour source d'autres
dimensions du multivers c'est l'ancien
elle-même qui nous l'expliquait dans le
film dédié de doctor strange au moment
où steven commence à être formés pour
devenir un sorcier ce qui veut dire que
strange dans nowhere home utilisent
d'autres dimensions du multivers pour
effectuer son sort donc le fait qu'il se
base sur les réalités de la trilogie de
sam raimi de mailing et d'autres pour
corriger le sien est totalement cohérent
mais également l'ancien nous expliquait
aussi que le langage des arts mystiques
pouvait être défini comme le code source
qui façonnent la réalité donc par le
biais de ses pouvoirs dr strange peut
interagir sur la réalité et c'est ce
qu'il fait avec son sort son sort qui a
été montré visuellement par le biais de
la scène post générique de venom 2 et 10
et venom sont tranquillement dans une
chambre d'hôtel avant que la réalité se
modifie pour les faire arriver dans
celle de nos héros et c'est là que c'est
intéressant puisque le sort possède un
code visuel qui n'est pas du tout anodin
nous retrouvons les mêmes effets
spéciaux de glitch et de bugs que quand
rwanda transformer la ville de west view
pour l'adapter à la vie qu'elle menait
sauf que pour rappel rwanda et la
scarlet witch scarlet witch qui est liée
à la magie du chaos et qui peuvent
façonner la réalité comme bon lui semble
et le truc c'est que quand wendat
réécrit la réalité en transformant ouest
vion et bien les habitants suivent et
leur vie est adapté également pour
coller à la nouvelle réalité que wendat
est en train de créer alors si strange
réécrit la réalité est que
malencontreusement cela fasse venir des
personnes qui ne sont pas issus du même
univers et bien leur vie et leur vécu
serait adapté à l'univers où ils ont été
transportés
et sa réécriture étant donné qu'il n'ya
pas du moins pour le moment de norman
osborn dans le mc eu et que c'est tony
stark qui existaient et qui possédait
les entreprises et bien la nature
d'électro serait adapté omc eu pour
coller à l'univers dans le sens où il
aurait travaillé pour starking du striz
et non pour osbourne industry's et par
conséquent cela expliquerait pourquoi
ses pouvoirs ont été modifiés pourquoi
il aurait un réacteur arc et pourquoi il
souhaite ne pas perdre sa nouvelle
condition et c'est exactement pareil
pour octopus dont la nature et
l'équipement est à la base lié à osborn
industry's eh bien tant le mc eu son
équipement serait adapté par rapport à
stark industries et par conséquent la
nanotechnologie et ce qui va avec c'est
une vision totalement personnelle que je
vous propose là mais cela permettrait
pour moi d'expliquer le changement
apporté à certains sinister et de façon
cohérente néanmoins il n'est pas
impossible également que ces changements
soient dus à la contribution d'un
sinister manquant il est vrai que nous
faisons face à un autre souci concernant
le groupe sait qu'ils sont 5 alors que
normalement on les appelle les sinister
6 et bien pour moi il existe deux cas de
figure par rapport à ce problème soit
effectivement il ya un sinister manquant
qui n'a pas encore été révélée et qui
servira de clé de voûte pour tous les
autres si ce dernier est bel et bien lié
au changement de visuel des autres
sinister cela signifie qu'il est
certainement issu de la réalité du mc ou
et par extension qu'il connaît les
travaux de tony stark il est clair que
mystérieux et celui qui collerait le
plus à cette idée étant donné qu'il
était un employé de stark industries zh
il connaît très bien tony et sa
technologie sans oublier également que
tout le film est à la base issue de sa
confrontation avec spider man et des
fausses révélations qui l'amenait à son
égard néanmoins ce dernier est
normalement bel et bien mort et dites
nous confirme même qu'il n'ya plus
d'illusions au moment de son décès donc
je reste plutôt mitigés par rapport à
lui le seul élément scénaristique
potentiel qu'ils puissent encore arrivé
par rapport à mystérieux pour moi c'est
que son groupe qui semble encore actifs
explique ce qui s'est réellement passé
et innocente peter quant à l'assassinât
de leur patron sinon certains pensaient
également à la présence de kingpin alias
wilson fisk le chef d'une organisation
criminelle et grand ennemi de spider man
personnage censé apparaître
prochainement dans le mc eu notamment
par le biais dockal possiblement pareil
c'est une idée qui pourrait coller mais
encore faut-il de justifier et
personnellement je ne suis pas sûr qu'on
ait le temps pour ça dans le film et du
coup le second cas de figure pour moi
serait que le groupe des sinistres sic
serait au final plus symbolique qu'autre
chose ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'il est possible qu'il n'y ait pas de
véritable groupe si mr 6 mais juste les
personnages qui le symbolise dans le
sens où contrairement aux comics où le
groupe est une initiative d'octopus pour
contrer spider man ici c'est juste des
vilains provenant d'autres univers et
qui souhaitent ne pas mourir étant donné
la nature de leur destin il s'allierait
un moment donné pour leur survie mais en
soit le dernier trailer nous a montré qu
octopus seraient plus enclins à aider
peter que les autres vilains l'homme
sable c'est avant tout un mec en cavale
qui n'avait rien de personnel contre
spider man le lézard était un ami du
père du peter dont andrew garfield et a
été raisonné par ce dernier à la fin du
film electro c'est juste un gars qui n'a
pas de chance et qui a été influencée
par les mauvaises personnes il n'y a que
le bouffon vert de willem dafoe qui est
foncièrement fou et méchante à l'origine
en soi pour la symbolique venom serait
au final
6e sinister étant donné que lui aussi il
a subi le changement de réalité comme
les autres c'est une idée comme une
autre à vous de définir ce que vous
croyez le plus pour le film maintenant
il faut qu'on parle de tobey maguire et
andrew garfield
évidemment je suis toujours un grand
partisan de leur présence le dernier
trailer on a d'ailleurs rajouté une
belle couche je pense personnellement
qu'il est un peu inutile de reprieve et
leur présence du coup j'aimerais plutôt
que l'on s'oriente vers l'impact qu'il
pourrait avoir dans le film c'est une
question que je trouve tout à fait
légitime car c'est bien beau d'avoir
trois spider man réunis mais on parle
quand même de tobey maguire et andrew
garfield des spider man avec une
histoire lourde pour chacun d'entre eux
et dont les méchants lié à leur passé
son présent aussi si ils sont là ils
auront forcément un impact plus
important que simplement épaulé le peter
de tom holland dans un combat face aux
sinistres heures déjà l'idée qu'andrew
garfield sauvé mj de sa chute dans nos
rôles est pour moi la meilleure idée qui
puisse arriver si andrew devait revenir
effectivement la mort de gwen stacy est
ce qui a marqué au fer rouge l'histoire
du peter d'andrew et tous les symboles
derrière ce drame sont hyper importants
endroit choisi d'écouter son coeur et
non sa raison il est resté proche de
gwen stacy elle a inclus à son histoire
d'homme araignée malgré la dangerosité
les énormes risques que cela pouvait
impliquer spider man est un héros qui
aura des ennemis et le capitaine stacy
le savez il l'avait averti pour gwen et
pourtant peter n'a pas respecté cette
promesse le peter de tom holland
pourrait donc se faire éduquer par celui
d'andrew lors de sa rédemption en
sauvant mj le spider man de tom inclus
ses meilleurs amis dans chaque mission
malgré la dangerosité et un jour il y
aura un drame
c'est ce qui semble se passer avec no et
comme nous sommes déjà témoin de la
chute de mj ou encore les blessures de
rapides rien qu'avec les trailer sauf
que tom ne sera pas toujours accompagné
il ne peut pas sauver tout le monde
comme il le dit une grosse remise en
question pourrait re surgir par rapport
à ces relations en tant que spider man
mais du coup toby dans tout ça et bien
déjà je pense que toby devrait jouer le
spider man un petit peu d'aaron étant
donné qu'il est issu de la plus ancienne
trilogie beaucoup pensent par exemple
qui pourrait être celui qui va dire la
fameuse phrase un grand pouvoir implique
de grandes responsabilités
franchement ce serait vraiment
incroyable néanmoins je me dis que si
andrew serait liée au sauvetage d'un
proche du peter deux tomes en
l'occurrence ici sa copine donc lié à
l'amour et bientôt bis pourrait lui
aussi être liée à quelqu'un avec une
autre thématique pour moi il n'y a pas
36 possibilités étant donné que tom est
toujours accompagné de deux personnes
peu importe où il va il se pourrait pour
moi que toby aurait un rapport avec ned
ce qui me fait penser ceci c'est que si
andrew à une rédemption liées à l'amour
avec le drame iconique de gwen stacy le
même schéma doit se retrouver avec toby
avec sa propre thématique phare pour moi
l'amitié serait cette thématique et
c'est pourquoi j'ai pensé à ned le peter
incarné par toby a toujours galéré en
amitié et sa relation avec son meilleur
ami a toujours été particulière ils se
sont beaucoup posé à cause d'éléments
externes à leur relation la mort du
bouffon vert n'a clairement pas du tout
aidé et leur amitié s'est effondré à
plusieurs reprises au final harry s'est
sacrifié pour sauver peter et sa mort a
marqué au fer rouge l'histoire de toby
concluant par la suite la trilogie de
sam raimi toby pourrait donc éduquer le
peter de tom par rapport à ses relations
amicales lui affirmant qu'un grand
pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités et que l'on a toujours
le choix de nos actes bon et maintenant
il faut que nous parlions de doctor
strange est du cas de venom déjà pour
moi il ya un truc hyper important à
souligner par rapport à strange c'est
que multiverse of madness sort dans cinq
mois kevin fille qui nous avait teasé
que huang la vision noeo mais multiverse
of madness serait une sorte de trilogie
et le fait que spider man et doctor
strange 2 soit si rapprochée de cinq
mois de différence ça cache forcément
des choses effectivement strange est
bizarre dans nos rôles mais je me dis
que nous aurons les réponses dans son
film dédié en fait il ya quelque chose
que l'on a tendance à négliger mais
depuis ngame strange n'est jamais
réapparue avant nos héros et cela
possède son importance car cela peut
sous-entendre des choses déjà dans la
scène post générique de change chinois
wang nous apprend que depuis k-mart âge
il a ressenti la puissance des dix
anneaux il fait même appel à banner ou
encore captain marvel pour en parler
mais strange dans tout ça ou est ce
qu'il est si longue à détecter la
puissance des dix anneaux strange
l'aurait détecter aussi mais surtout
étant le sorcier suprême huang devrait
normalement avertir strange de ce qu'il
a vu mais non il a réuni banner et
captain marvel à la place donc cela
signifierait que strange n'est pas là et
certainement il ne serait même pas sur
terre à ce moment là il est possible que
depuis une game et vu la tendance
multiverse de la phase 4 strange
expérimente des choses voyage et se
forment sur tout ça cela pourrait
notamment expliqué son sortilèges d'en
nommer comme ayant appris plusieurs
choses depuis ngame avec son côté
espiègle et son ego surdimensionné il
aurait tenté d'aider peter comme un
expert alors qu'il a encore beaucoup à
apprendre d'ailleurs un moment des
thrillers que je trouve pertinent c'est
le moment où strange et face aux brèches
ouvertes on s'attend tous à ce qu'un
combat éclate suite à ça mais cela ne
semble pas être le cas du tout le codes
visuels des arts mystiques de strange
nous montre qu'il lance une incantation
tout comme dans endgame quand ils
essaient de maintenir l'eau en dehors du
champ de bataille il n'est pas du tout
en formation de combat avec ses deux
anneaux mystique au bout des mains il se
pourrait donc que strange passe la
majeure partie du film à réparer son
erreur
tenter de refermer les brèches ou
quelque chose dans le genre et du coup
bas cela expliquerait également son rôle
un peu plus secondaire dans le film dans
tous les cas le mc ou instaurer des
règles par rapport à strange et sa
condition de sorcier strange ne combat
que des grosses entité cosmique ou multi
vercel comme dormammu thanos et
possiblement shuma gorath ou encore au
rwanda à l'avenir mais bref pas
d'humains land art comme les sinister le
déséquilibre est trop grand et c'est à
spider man de briller donc strange sera
occupée quelque part le temps que speedy
agissent par rapport à venom et la fin
du film il serait attendu que ce dernier
apparaissent avant tout dans une scène
post-générique finalement ce qui est
intéressant avec ça vous en avez
certainement entendu parler c'est qu'une
nouvelle trilogie spider man a été
négocié entre marvel et sony pour la
presse nous sommes donc le cas de venom
servirait finalement pour un quatrième
film avec possiblement une histoire
dédié et là en vrai tout notre vision
change complètement puisque avec cette
nouvelle trilogie eh bien on est
clairement plus libre on n'est pas
obligé d'avoir 40 personnes dans nos et
home ils vont pouvoir étaler tout ça et
du coup à venom servirait pour tease et
un quatrième film et franchement ce
n'est pas plus mal car vais nommer
clairement un cas à part dans les
vilains de l'araignée et si un film
dédié prévu pour lier les deux
personnages cela peut donner quelque
chose de vraiment super toute façon on
en parlait mais il faut que venom
absorbe les pouvoirs de peter pour
évoluer et atteindre sa véritable forme
des comics et pour spider man sa
confrontation avec venom est un point
clé dans l'histoire du héros et son
développement d'ailleurs cette nouvelle
trilogie permettrait de répondre
également aux teasing du scorpion dans
homecoming qui n'est toujours pas
présent on peut penser à king pin
également qui est censé arriver
prochainement mais évitons de trop nous
et aller on aura tout le temps
d'exploiter tout ça après la sortie du
film en revanche les films spider man du
mc y possède toujours deux scène post
générique la première liée à spider man
et donc sony et l'autre omc eu en
général et donc par extension marvel
studios si venom est attendu pour la
scène post générique cela veut dire que
cela serait passé dédié à l'univers de
spider man et par conséquent sony mais
du coup qu'en est il de la scène liés
opencl et bien personnellement cela me
semble évident que ce serait une scène
lié à multiverse of madness pour toutes
les raisons qu'on a déjà énoncé
auparavant et personnellement étant
donné l'ouverture des réalités trois
possibilités s'offrent à nous déjà il a
de grandes chances que tout ne soit pas
véritablement réparer à la fin du film
concernant l'ouverture des réalités et
marvel pourrait appuyer là-dessus pour
teese est le second film du docteur
première possibilité nous sommes témoins
de l'arrivée d'amérique h chavez cette
dernière pour rappel est attendu pour
apparaître dans doctor strange 2 avec un
rôle plutôt important et c'est une
héroïne qui vient d'une autre réalité à
la base justement seconde possibilité un
teasing de luanda deux par la fin de
warda vision ou honda a clairement
évolué et épousé son rôle de scarlet
witch puisqu'elle semble chercher ses
enfants qu'elle a entendu elle pourrait
profiter de l'erreur de strange pour
commencer à voyager à travers le
multivers pour ses objectifs personnels
et enfin troisième possibilité la
présence de chaume agora ce show magot
race est attendu pour être une grosse
entité de doctor strange 2 je vous
invite à voir cette vidéo si vous voulez
en savoir plus mais shuma-gorath est une
entité très ancienne qui voyage à
travers les réalités et qui sèment le
chaos dans ces dernières mais surtout il
a déjà été teasé deux fois dans what if
et à chaque fois c'est quand un portail
multi vercel a été ouvert étant donné
que strange ouvre les portes de son
monde dans nos oreilles comme on
retrouverait cette même cohérence bon qu
est ce qu on pourrait rajouter à tout ça
et bien personnellement je pense qu'il
faut une mort importante dans le film
pour faire évoluer la mentalité de peter
von coming et far from était plutôt
gentille et noé rom c'est clairement une
transition de fou pour une nouvelle ère
une feinte de trilogie spider man il va
falloir un drame spider man est un héros
qui a des morts dans son entourage et le
peter de tom holland ne fera pas
exception pour moi la mort de tentes
mais serait une bonne idée ça n'a encore
jamais été vu dans les films spider man
et cela permettrait pourquoi pas
d'amener l'arc one more day as avec le
fameux méphisto pourquoi pas ou bien la
limite api qui est devenu un petit peu
une nouvelle figure paternelle pour
l'araignée
bon écoute et voilà je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter là c'était une longue vidéo
mais au moins on a pu revenir sur tous
les points que j'estimais important pour
nommer home
j'espère avoir tout dit et surtout
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu nous
sommes très proches de la sortie
officielle du film ça fait vraiment
bizarre j'ai très hâte en attendant je
vous invite à aller voir la vidéo du
broue recef une vidéo qui va traiter du
destin des trois spider man dans no et
home et où j'apparais également dedans
je vous invite également à vous abonner
à nos chaînes a laissé un petit pouce
bleus et surtout à un commentaire avec
ce que vous attendez le plus pour le
film de noël je vous invite également à
voir les anciennes vidéos dédiées et
puis écouter bas que le lionheart soit
avec vous c'était un argot rock allez
ciao tonneaux
[Musique]